you can watch this and other programs
online at book TV org
[Music]
goodmorning goodmorning proven once
again that if you want a nice crowd
serve some food
but we do have a great crowd here today
thank you very much everyone for coming
on behalf of the National Review
Institute it's president Lindsey Craig
and my fellow trustees including
here-and-now rich Lowry and Stan town if
I forgotten anyone you'll let me know
later I would like to welcome you to
this special conversation about an
important book an important new book a
torch kept lit great lives of the 20th
century my name is Jack Fowler and I'm
the publisher of National Review but we
will applaud National Review the
Institute is our sister organization a
non-profit educational entity founded 25
years ago by William F Buckley Jr its
mission its mission is to advance the
conservative principles Bill champion
complement the mission of the magazine
support national reviews best talent and
preserve and promote the Buckley legacy
indeed the Institute has formally
launched its buckley legacy project and
there was literature here explaining its
plans and vision in this last year the
Institute through this project has
celebrated the anniversaries of two
important and lasting aspects of the
Buckley legacy Bills 1965 mayoral run
brilliantly captured in his now
republished campaign memoir the unmaking
of a mayor and the 1966 launch of Bill's
marvelous interview program firing line
the Buckley legacy is why we are here
today
to discuss bill the writer and
specifically bill the observer of men
and women public and private Giants and
small fries before I introduce our
participants a related anecdote over 20
years ago my predecessor at Capano who
is here today and to whom National
Review owes so much that'll be 10 bucks
said our 20 had us had a terrific idea
let's have NR publish a collection of
bills obits we collected them all
consulted priscilla buckley bills
beloved sister who agreed terrific idea
already we approached bill he couldn't
say no fast enough for a long time after
ed and i remain perplexed the idea was a
surefire success why because we believed
then as we believe now and as we see now
through this marvelous book james rosen
has edited that among bills many talents
this one where he remembered the recent
dead for posterity with deep insight and
elegant prose would be embraced not only
by national review readers but by the
public at large bill was no dope he knew
what we knew so ed and I eventually
deduced that bill was hoarding his RI PS
for his own collections and indeed he
did sprinkle some and ensuing books
including near oh my god miles gone by
and Buckley the right word but there are
so many of these gems that the thought
of a necessary collection remained valid
over the years along comes 2014 and
along come
Rossum through a conversation about
another idea James
raised this I'd like to do a collection
of bills eulogies remembrances
obituaries and our IPS what do you think
it was like asking me if I wanted a bag
of peanut M&Ms of course I said so did
Christopher Buckley who oversees all
things literary for the Buckley Estate
probably all things for the Buckley
Estate not only literary well we were
off to the races
Campbell Wharton and the good people at
Crown Forum also agreed and here now we
have this wonderful book I have not had
this conversation with Campbell but I
can't help but think he knows what we
all know that although he left us eight
years ago
Bill Buckley in many ways still looms
very large the song asks where have you
gone Joe DiMaggio likewise a
conservative America asks the same about
Bill there is a longing the appetite for
his wisdom remains very strong coming up
next is a conversation about Bill
Buckley the man of prose the man who
wrote history person by person through
his particular talent it is not a
conversation about politics the
elections or the often dismaying game of
if Bill Buckley were alive today what
would he say about blank so at the end
of the conversation questions will be
entertained you will find cards on the
table feel free to write down your
question will collect the cards and hand
them to the moderator who will pick and
choose and about the moderator he is my
friend and colleague the very
big-brained Rahan salaam Rahan is
executive editor of National Review and
a policy fellow of the National Review
Institute he is the co-author of grand
new party how conservatives can win the
working class and
save the American dream and he has a
book coming out in early 2017 on
immigration I look forward to the
conversation about that book next year
another friend a good one a dear one and
we are so pleased to have him with us
this morning is Christopher Buckley his
approval of this project and his ensuing
encouragement of a torch kept lit are so
genuine and deeply appreciated the only
son of Bill and Pat Buckley Christopher
was educated at Portsmouth Abbey and
graduated [ __ ] laude from Yale he is the
former managing editor of Esquire
magazine and was the founding editor of
Forbes fYI he knows a thing or two about
books having written 16 or so many of
them exceptional satires I must really
encourage you to read his most recent
the relic master it is a marvelous novel
the centers on a scam and the Shroud of
Turin if you laugh you will need to go
to confession and a personal side oh I
went to bed alone last night because my
wife was up til the wee hours reading
and laughing at a 22 year old
Christopher Buckley novel little green
men thanks pal around this buyout by
saying he was chief speechwriter to the
vice president of the United States
George HW Bush and has received the
Washington Irving prize for literary
excellence and the Thurber prize for
American humor last but not least a new
friend and a man who inspired this book
and who is as big a contributor to it in
beautiful prose as was Bill Buckley and
that is James Rosen the chief Washington
correspondent for Fox News James has
covered the White House and the State
Department beats and reported from
Capitol Hill
the Pentagon the Supreme Court nearly
all 57 states
sorry 50 and yep-yep-yep
40 foreign countries across five
continents
Rosen's articles and essays have
appeared in The New York Times Wall
Street Journal the Washington Post
Harper's and National Review this is not
his first book James as the author of
the strong man John Mitchell and the
secrets of Watergate and also Cheney
one-on-one Friends of Bill and not only
the 12-step kind should know that this
man is a walking talking Buckley Legacy
Project his knowledge about Bill and his
belief in bills lasting importance and
relevance and how we need to realize
that immense power for good resides in
the Buckley legacy is second to none it
has been a delight to work with him and
I congratulate James not only for the
excellent book he assembled but also for
his own smart prose providing the
context in which all the bills collected
remembrances are set in a torch kept lit
and on that note ladies and gentlemen
right hon Salaam
thanks very much jack for that very kind
introduction
and thanks also to my national review
Institute colleagues for helping to put
together this event
I'm enormous ly honored to be here with
two of the most distinguished writers
and thinkers in America today you you
look you know you you kid but it's true
James I wanted to ask you what on earth
land a perfectly healthy sane person to
become so obsessed with Bill Buckley
first and second to this project in
particular first of all my thanks to
everyone for coming this morning and to
all of my friends at National Review in
the National Review Institute and to
Christopher and for hosting this event I
have to tell you that I feel a little
like delag being up here at all and to
have my name on the same jacket as Bill
Buckley's it's kind of surreal for me so
I that's not just false humility its
humility with an asterisk
perhaps but so I I learned about Bill
Buckley for the first time from The
Tonight Show seeing him with Johnny
Carson and here was this guy who had
this strange accent but was very
good-looking and who kind of seemed to
be a treating Johnny as an equal as
opposed to most people went on The
Tonight Show and were just very grateful
to be there and I remember on that
occasion and I've tried to find the date
in the tape of it with no success
I think it was around 1985 Johnny said
to him bill why is it whenever you come
here on the set I feel like I'm in the
principal's office
and I thought I want to be like that guy
and so commenced a kind of an obsession
my wife who is here today and who just
say hi to everyone this is my lovely
wife Sarah joking
who is the the unsung suffering heroine
and all of my exploits you know I she
has seen that I have many obsessions and
and I'm and and I'm intense about them
and in case of Bill Buckley I know so
many people Christopher from Fred Barnes
and other people who've said the same
thing I want to be like that guy and in
any case this book began a few years ago
I was writing something for National
Review about Richard Nixon and I was
trying to find a particular piece that
bill had done about him called
is Nixon one of them I remembered the
headline I knew was from 1971 I was
laboring however under the
misapprehension that it had appeared in
National Review
I finally consulted a book called
William F Buckley Jr a bibliography
which was published in 2002 when Bill
was alive
and it was just an annotated collection
of and sort of a listing of all of his
works and therein I learned that it had
been in The Times magazine the editor of
that volume said someday someone should
do a volume of bills eulogies because
they're really elegant and often
shattering works and I thought with a
smidgen of clips but why not me and and
I'm just grateful to be associated with
it I'm going to jump in I was asked to
give a blurb for this book and I bet the
risk it's the height of vanity to quote
one's own blur it's such a good blur but
I can't William F Buckley Jr was a
master of many things
this collection of obituaries and
eulogies that he wrote over the course
of his extraordinary career admirably
curated and eloquently introduced by
James Rosen may well establish WFP as
the modern master of this literary form
I have read this is nothing I have read
every single one of my father's 60 odd
books I do not exaggerate to propose
that this may prove could be William F
Buckley finest book ever and I mean that
thank you so much Hansie no thank you
it I mean I I had read a lot of these I
suppose you know as as they came out and
I I was never it his I was never failed
to be moved but an elegant sentence that
was um but it wasn't until I saw them
all in in toto
but that it that it came to me that I
think this is William F Buckley is most
beautiful writing there are I think you
started with you called from about 250
obituaries and eulogies published in
National Review in in a syndicated
column but also also elsewhere including
Forbes FY High and some delivered as
actual you and Samuel is our vacuum
eulogies there are and I think you ended
up with 52 on the subway down here this
morning unlike my father I rode the
subway once mentioned the word subway to
and he said what would that be but on
the way down in the subway i I did a
count of of the 52 in the in the table
of contents and put a check next to each
person that he knew personally and it
came out to 33 33 out of 52 and these
are pretty you know pretty pretty big
people so including Pat Buckley I mean
he knew in the biblical sense as well I
suppose I am proof and we we have here
with us of the white
of one of the people pups best friend
Dan Galbraith we have Marie Galbraith
here how glad I am to to see Bootsy but
it's no it's it's it's an extraordinary
collection and is off to a very good
start not not only I think because
because it is such a good book and it's
and by the way your introductions to
each one of the 52 pieces are mini
masterpieces and in this very kind of
bomb this guy you may know this guy
mostly as a Fox News TV guy but let me
tell you this son of a gun can write and
then the he vs. succeed you in getting
it from anyway so in part because of
James's James being a very old name out
there in TV land the book is off to a
brilliant start and I he was on bill
Bill O'Reilly gave it a very nice plug a
couple of days ago and I did something I
actually don't do a lot I went to Amazon
to check his sales ranking know most all
authors say there but I thought it was
legit to check someone else's and it was
number two
so I thought email James James here
became a tad aloof he said well you know
I don't I really don't spend a lot of
time looking at my Amazon sales rating
this morning
fresh from Megan Kelly last night he
said to me a check it's number one
James I wonder Chris mentioned a moment
ago that you called these obituaries
from very rich source material there are
many many more things that you might
have published in this collection
tell us a bit about how you disciplined
yourselves and how you made your
selections well here thanks for due to
the great folks at crown publishing
everyone needs an editor and and and
they were great in helping me focus so
we found about two hundred two hundred
twenty eulogies and obituaries and
remembrances that that bill wrote we had
a whole section in the book that
unfortunately for space reasons we had
to excise of just devoted to movement
conservatives and we rescued a few of
those people like Barry Goldwater and
Russell Kirk and we we sort of cast them
into a diaspora where where they went
into some of the other chapters that
remained what we wanted to do was basic
break it down by types of people he was
remembering so there's a section for
presidents of the United States there's
a section for Phil's own family members
so there's eulogies for his mother his
father his wife and his brother-in-law
Brent Bozell
there's a section for Arts and Letters
figures I like to say that a torch kept
lit is the only place in the world where
you will find Milton Friedman rubbing
elbows with Jerry Garcia that's in the
Arts and Letters section also in Arts
and Letters and this speaks to Bill
Buckley's breadth of interests and
intellectual curiosity there are
eulogies for Jerry Garcia and John
Lennon and Elvis Presley
he was an Elvis man Bill Buckley he
actually went to Graceland he actually
wrote an entire novel about Elvis
Presley late in his career there's a
section for friends not all of the
people in the friend section are
household names some of them are people
only really known to the Buckley family
I would imagine in terms of readers and
one of the things about this book I
think a recurring theme in it is
friendship
I don't think Bill Buckley would have
copped to the term genius I think he
would have been in a rare moment of
modesty I think he would have recoiled
from the term genius but everyone who
knew him oh I don't know
there is only one expert on this stage
about a little bucket but everyone that
I've spoken to who knew him well has
attested that Bill Buckley had a genius
for friendship and he was very
passionate about his friends and
maintained friendships as Bootsy can
attest in some cases over 60 years time
the last eulogy he wrote or published
was for Van Galbraith who had been his
friend by the time they that they died
within a short time of each other for 60
years and he cultivated friendships he
he invested in them he cared deeply
about them I dare say that the giving of
this book to a friend for whatever
occasion will deepen one's friendship
with those friends lastly there's a
section called nemec's and I have to
confess that this is my favorite section
because these are eulogies and
obituaries for people who pre deceased
Bill and with whom he had done battle
over the course of his extraordinary
career people like Alger Hiss people
like John V Lindsay and as you can see
there's a spectrum of awfulness and
Arthur Schlesinger Eleanor Roosevelt and
they and the fun in this chapter is
watching bill struggle to find something
kind to say about these people or
alternatively not bothering and one last
word about this these are pieces that
were often written on deadlines and in
situations where the writer himself
because he knew 33 of the 52 people was
himself often wracked with guilt guilt
grief is what I meant to say he he was
himself mourning these people in many
cases and that he put together such
brilliant prose lyrical prose about
these people whom he personally knew
when he was himself suffering from grief
at their loss speaks a lot to his
discipline I he was a man of devout
faith as we all know and that is the
eulogy which is I believe is technically
not a part of the Catholic Mass bill
venerated something called the patrimony
which was the inherited
of truths earthly and celestial that get
passed down through the millennia and
which are in arguable and conservatives
believe in objective truths and one of
them is that people die but God indoors
and I think that infused these writings
as well Chris had a question for you as
a writer so and this is for both of you
though I do want to hear your
perspective on this bill buckley with
both America's most celebrated public
intellectual yet he was also a writer
and singer of independent mind and he
was also the architect of a political
movement and as such it occurs to me
that sometimes one might be political in
how one is describing other figures and
how its navigating this larger landscape
do you feel as though he ever pulled his
punches in deference to his
responsibilities as the leader of a
movement that you know ganda just
curious to hear your thoughts no pulling
punches was as James was talking it
occurred to me I was sort of sorry the
pop pre deceased gore Vidal I'd uh I'd
like to have read that it's a [ __ ]
where do you think he was done one by
the way or do you think he might have
not even graced him with one no I don't
I don't think so here's one of the
remarkable things you will know about
blowing up Buckley's history with gore
vidal's on somebody who probably seen
the celebrated documentary the best of
enemies about the famous exchange in
1968 and there you know which
precipitated lawsuits and also it's like
a pop was huh let go of gore Vidal he
know he the only time I ever mentioned
gore vidal's dinner table whatever was
in the context of his delight in some
witticism that gore Vidal had rendered
when remember the gore Vidal was offered
a given awarded election to the American
Academy of Arts and Letters and and he
replied he his reply to them was thanks
I already have
card Pablo this is about the wittiest
thing he had ever heard apparently now I
have not I purposely didn't have not
seen the documentary but apparently gore
Vidal was obsessed with hip hop and wood
is it came up all the time and he would
when he had friends over for dinner
afterwards he would screen the famous
debate in 1968 I think in the in the
documentary they used a clip from the
movie Sunset Boulevard where glorious
Norma Desmond played by Gloria Swanson
sitting there watching her old movies
one old Queen measured against another
but the to James's point about pops
genius for friendship even as you as you
point out in your brilliant introduction
even in these you know dozen odd nemesis
categories you can see pops struggling
to find something nice to say now this I
think came from his deep deep deep sense
of Christianity which were so animated
him you know if I can jump in on to the
point of whether he pulled punches these
remembrances aren't strictly celebratory
even in the case of lionized figures and
people who are iconic in the
conservative firmament so for example
his eulogy for Winston Churchill whom
Buckley had gone to see speak personally
in 1949 is is not hagiographic for
Winston Churchill he celebrates the
accomplishments of Churchill up through
and including the victory in World War
two but then false Churchill for
continuing to stay in office when he
didn't have the stamina to prosecute the
Cold War properly with the ensuing
result that what one-third of the of the
world's people at the time wound up
behind the Iron Curtain
similarly for Martin Luther King who in
today's
a landscape we conceived of in almost
gauzy terms when Bill Buckley wrote his
remembrance of Martin Luther King in
April 1968 after his assassination
Buckley wrote a column that was tough on
Martin Luther King celebratory of his
accomplishments in civil rights but at
the same time a condemned Natori of some
statements that Martin Luther King had
made about America at the height of the
Vietnam War and its role in the world
that he thought were utterly
inappropriate so he didn't always pull
his punches even when he was discussing
people who are lionized on the right and
that speaks I think to build
intellectual integrity or was this to
some degree a kind of puckish contrarian
ism just a sense that some figures had
become too big to over large celebrated
inappropriately or was it purely the
sense that I must get the record right I
think it's the latter the one of the
themes and within this book is under the
general rubric of the gift for
friendship was his relationship with
arguably the leading in liberal
intellectual of of our time John Kenneth
Galbraith this was a friendship that
dated to 1966 pop and John Kenneth
Galbraith met in an elevator at the
Plaza Hotel on their way to Truman
Capote's famous black-and-white ball the
party of the century as it was Hardy of
the century as you point out in your van
say again brilliant introduction you can
say it as often as you like I cannot I
cannot say this enough if you read this
book for one reason read it for the
introduction house but you've gone crazy
talk but they you know I don't think of
Tom and John Kenneth Galbraith would
have agreed on the time of day but this
became one of his deepest friendships
and as Ken Ken Dodd I think he was in
his 90s
and he had been I think bedridden for
well you know years and every three
weeks pump would get on the train in
Stanford and go up to Boston and just
sit by his bedside and at a certain
point ken was no longer conversational
due to his ailment public Pacific the
last trip I made with pop was to John
Kenneth Galbraith memorial service that
eulogy is contained in here at his their
relationship was a teasing on a mutually
teasing on a very grand level when when
Nixon resigned Papa Nixon's resignation
was inconvenient for pop because we he
had scheduled he was going sailing on
his boat with me as it happened and this
is 1974 every you know his phone started
ringing with you know CBS and you see
and you see all and wanted comments
whose I'm going going sailing and CBS
NBC and ABC said watch will send a
helicopter said no I don't have a
landing platform on my thirty-six would
say of it anyway so his syndicated
column that ran after Nixon's
resignation was a canned column that
this is what columnist did when they
went on vacation like you know write a
column Mahendran this one was I think on
the subject of peanut butter which is
one of the pups great so can the next
week wrote poppy said well bill I think
it's just marvelous that after one of
the most important events in American
political history that you chose to
write your column about peanut butter
and pop replied can you don't understand
when I relax I write columns about
peanut butter when you relax you write
economic textbooks
and you know I think in your may I say
one more time
brilliant introduction you quote John
Kerry conversation that has hopped in
the context of the friendship with John
Kenneth Galbraith and John Kerry no
conservative I think said to you
directly love Bill Buckley and of their
at apropos the friendship he said that's
what's missing in politics today
yeah we're and and it is you mentioned
in passing James about the breadth of
Bill Buckley interests including his
interest in pop culture something that
would be a little bit surprising to
those who only knew him as this arch
traditionalist tell us a little bit
about his encounters with the world of
pop well Bill Buckley wrote a column in
1964 after the Beatles arrived in
America and played the Ed Sullivan Show
pronouncing them not just awful but
god-awful and saying in essence that
they were so horribly auntie musical
that they would go down in history with
respect to music the way the anti-popes
were recorded in the history of
Catholicism to this day there there are
there are there are and I'm a huge
Beatles freak my two sons their actual
middle names is Lennon and McCartney
McCartney and this is evidence of my
neurosis and Sarah's patience but if you
have a girl please don't name her yoga
deal and there are there are there are
collections of writings about the
Beatles and that buckley column is
routinely included in them as a sort of
jewel of early Philistine even a
Philistine isn't about the band he later
committed one of the most spectacular
reversals of his entire career for which
probably 99% of the credit is due to
Christopher in a column in 1968 called
how I came to Rock and in which he sit
he acknowledged that there is simply an
exuberance about the Beatles that is
unmatched and
one cannot resist them and when we come
to a little perhaps a little later in
the discussion I would love to know how
you converted bill Buckley on the
subject of the Beatles but in writing
that first column where he pronounced
them god-awful he said if you know I
liked Elvis Presley and in fact he later
in his career Buckley pronounced that
Elvis had the most beautiful singing
voice of any person on earth there's a
there there is an intent by Buckley to
engage with the counterculture and in
earnest one he wanted to know what it
was all about in the eulogy for Jerry
Garcia he recounts that there was a
young man who worked for National Review
who was an outbound deadhead and he
begins the column and here's remember
I'm going to slip in the impersonation I
think which I vowed not to go ahead well
I lie I lie a lot if I ever heard a song
made by the Grateful Dead I was unaware
of it he said and and but he he saw the
deterioration in this young man not only
in his upkeep but his his reliability
and so forth and he pondered in eulogy
for Jerry Garcia the influence of Jerry
Garcia on legions of young people in
cruising speed which was an account of
one week in bills life that's hugely
entertaining was published in 1971 he
recounts going with Pat Buckley and
another couple that was a friend of
theirs to go see Gimme Shelter the
documentary about the Rolling Stones and
and the horrific concert at Altamont one
wonders how many leading conservative
voices today would go see a documentary
like Gimme Shelter so he cared about it
and he engaged with it over a long
period of time and when John Lennon was
killed in 1980 he began his column about
it his eulogy for Lennon of whom he had
been critical in the 1970s when Lennon
was spouting off on this and that by
quoting Christopher who said to him pup
imagine if Arturo Toscanini had just
been shot to death how would you have
felt and Buckley wrote that John Lennon
didn't speak to me in essence he said
for those of us who were unmoved by his
work still we gaze upon the
out of a hundred thousand people weeping
in Central Park holding candles and we
we must acknowledge the grief is real so
he had a real interest in pop culture
even if it didn't always speak to him
directly to two footnotes in 1964 my
father and I were on a commercial flight
from Copenhagen now yeah Copenhagen to
Geneva and we were in the front row
old coach and guess who boarded the
plane just before takeoff the Rolling
Stones and I am 12 years old
to quote my 28 year old daughter now oh
my god
and they were sitting right behind us
they were heavily perfumed and with the
Cologne of the air I said to pop and he
sort of missing the point in the another
footnote to Yoko I believe I have this
right Yoko would remember at one point
the United States was going to expel
John Lennon they were going to revoke
his green card on I think on the grounds
that there have been a drug bus
somewhere in the past as there always it
is it's so rare it was rock critic of
drug violation yell coke came to see pop
and asked him if he would write a letter
to the to the relevant Authority against
the AI NS on John Lennon's behalf he did
did she come to see him at your house or
a no sir no I believe it was National
Review and she and that I don't know if
the pup was the tipping point and there
were obviously other letters but you
know letter from Bill Buckley to the two
a Nixon rules government agency would
not have been uninfluential timeout okay
timeout c-span timeout I'm a news guy
that's what I do for a living we just
got news folks Yoko Ono visited the
offices of National Review that's worth
the price of admission today alone
that's actually embargoed for I guess
footnote two-and-a-half I when Lennon
was assassinated I like many of my
generation you know went into a an
actual depression you know I mean this
was a staggering event and and pop
noticed my I mean I sit there the dinner
cables so if not speak and pop had to
write a column that night and he came
over to my garage apartment and said why
don't you write my column and I I
couldn't do that I'm sorry I couldn't do
it and I remember if you were well
because the what he wrote is in this
splendid and very attractively packaged
and reasonably priced book but it
concludes it concludes by he says he
said he says John what I now realize is
that John Lennon had gravitas and
gravitas was a quality pup greatly
esteemed so here was there there you
have the evolution the education of
William F Buckley from the 1964 deal to
to 1980 connect can I add one more
footnote to this I wanted to include
this in the introduction to the John
Lennon eulogy but ran out of space so I
had to excise it in 1970 John Lennon
gave a massively long and bilious
interview to Rolling Stone magazine
probably what a point where he was at
his most bitter and it's a landmark in
terms of the literature of the Beatles
and he was very negative and he called
the Beatles the biggest bastards on
earth and and you know he was just full
of acid comments about Paul and
everything else and and Bill Buckley
read the entire interview from start to
finish and I think it was something like
50,000 words over to issues of Rolling
Stone magazine and he devoted a column
to it and it's I think he he said that
John Lennon's autobiography should be
entitled how I wrecked my life and how I
can help you wreck yours and he talks
about the solipsism of John Lennon and I
think if John Lennon had lived much
longer too ripe age he would have looked
back with some regret on a lot of the
comments and at 1970 interview but in
writing about the interview in his
column
Buckley at one point he used a numbered
device where number one in the number
two and he quoting various things
gentleman and said and at a certain
point the way Buckley put it he said
something too defective John wrote all
the good songs not so for Paul semicolon
and they went on to other numbered
points and what up struck me about it
was that even Bill Buckley fell prey to
Beatle mania in a sense because he was
referring to them by their first names
the way the rest of the world does
Paul said I don't think there's any any
record of ever having uttered the word
Ringo now here's a scholarly project so
I want to get to questions from the
audience before I do however James might
you have any questions for Christopher
mmm yes can you tell us again how
brilliant I am
hahaha
[Laughter]
so Christopher and I have only met once
before today about ten or twelve years
ago and that was her sort and I should
point out too that at no point after
providing his assent that the project
may go forward did he seek any input or
control over them till the very end
and there was yeah and there was one
eulogy that we had looked at and and
again for space reasons not included
that he has to be included and and we
did so but so so you know there was no
attempt at control here there is a some
there's a lady who's written half a
dozen well-regarded biographies and then
she wrote her own memoir and it was kind
of a lessons to aspiring biographers and
the title of that memoir was complete
with the exclamation mark at the end
shoot the widow as the very first piece
of business that any aspiring biographer
should do when they're undertaking their
first bit of work on someone's blog
review shoot the widow because with yoko
ono perhaps is the archetype they seek
to control than the the narratives and
access to materials and so forth and
christopher engage in none of that so
this is really properly speaking my
first meeting with christopher which is
a great thrill for me and there were a
couple of questions sort of fanboy
questions that I had and I have not
shared with these with him in advance
but let me just take out the piece of
know and first of all Bill's handwriting
was terrible hmm Pop's handwriting so
bad that at Yale in the late 1940s he
actually he sought and was given
permission to type his exam since
remember the blue the blue book the blue
exam book which the mention of which
still makes me break up is all the
professor said yes for god sakes but in
fact so he would go into an adjoining
classroom while everyone else was
scribbling in Lindzi [ __ ] 101 and and
bang
out his his his exams tour here's
another orthographical quite the right
word
toward the end pup became very casual in
his class small as he would say of his
fingers on the keyboard he would just
sort of put him down anywhere and start
the result that his emails resembled the
Enigma no I cannot I can't be fun to put
together a collection abode that would
be a talent I got for your brilliant
introduction I mean quite literally you
know if dear Krista would be spelled J
kx4 paranthesis and I would have to call
him up and say pop you know I I really
want to know what you've had like here
like your kid's gonna have to resend it
you know well I only exchanged emails
with Bill a few times and they've truly
were they looked like something you know
sort of like one of those jumbles you're
supposed to unscramble or whatever and
at the bottom he said PS I'm not drunk I
just typed this way I cherished that
email
did he ever once explicitly give you any
advice about the craft of writing oh
sure sure his first bit of advice I
think I was 14 he said Krista don't ever
become a professional writer he was head
he was it was a Saturday as weekend it
was dinner was over and he was heading
back to his study to you know bang out a
10,000 word article for Esquire that was
due Monday I did not take that advice he
was a you know it occurred
to me another theme with pop Assad you
know his give his genius for friendship
was his genius for mentoring i there i
think it's accurate to say that they're
the two great magazine editor mentors of
our time over Charlie Peters of the
Washington Monthly whose list of alumni
Jon Meacham James Fallows Michael
Kinsley it's endless and and William F
Buckley if you look at the list of
people who started at National Review
David Brooks by the way did you know
that David Brooks story he told it and
as in a column after pop dot it was
called I think remembering the mentor
pup in 1983 wrote a book called
overdrive which was a a sequel if you
will to a one of his best books which
was cruising speed which he published in
1973 which was a week in his very busy
life it was a marvelous way of doing a
pup never did a memoir but he did two
memoirs of two weeks in his life the 19
1983 was uh I was not it's not
particularly well received there was a
little bit too much about you know the
splendors of his limousine and you know
all the famous people he knew and a and
a scathing parrot but brilliant parody
of it was written by David Brooks for
the University of Chicago newspaper and
pop happened the next week to be
speaking at the University of Chicago
and so he's up there on stage and he
reads this scathing a parody of his book
aloud the in toto verb a
and then looks up and says if David
Brooks is in the audience I'd like to
offer him a job David relates that
scoring now I'm going to shame David
Brooks
now David Brooks is a well-regarded New
York Times columnist and author in his
own right I have a friend in Washington
who collects all kinds of memorabilia
and then gives them to me
often and he recently gave me a
beautiful handsome copy of the hardcover
edition of one of Bill's books called on
the firing line which was his memoir of
firing line the show and it is
autographed by Bill Buckley - David
Brooks I don't know how that happened
but David's got some explaining to do
one last one last point I would make
about Bill Buckley's mentorship as a
magazine editor I'm very grateful to
have with us today rich Lowry the editor
in chief of National Review and I'm sure
he - all right my last question for
Christopher if I may you know
unfortunately we're going to go to wrap
up soon okay let's do briefly ask two
quick questions from the audience all
right one of which is a practical
question it is often the case it's a
convention and the writing of obituaries
that many obituaries will be pre-written
that seems rather morbid but it happens
to be effective of the business is that
something that Bill Buckley would do
from time to time yeah so for example
the the obituary in there of Dwight
Eisenhower was written as Eisenhower was
dying and you know Hillsdale there are a
few places I really should mention
National Review opened up its digital
archive to me so that I could research
all of these pieces the Hoover
Institution maintains the the firing
line archive out in California and I
relied on their synopsis and
transcriptions of various episodes but
also Hillsdale College has on its
website the complete works of William F
Buckley Jr each column and there's in
PDF forms so that you can actually see
the typed manuscript that went off to
newspapers and there are instructions in
the one for Eisenhower for example or it
says if Eisenhower has not yet died by
date
then run this if he has died please
correct paragraphs three or so where
he's speaking in a different tent and
that sort of thing so and in fact for
alistair cooke who was a great towering
literary figure and broadcasting figure
and a friend of Buffy's for thirty years
he wrote three eulogies and obituaries
and one of them he wrote before cook had
died and he actually sent it to alistair
cooke who returned it to buckley
unopened and unread one more question or
is there one obituary you absolutely
heat your editors a crown for forcing
you to leave out of the book hate is a
strong word rock on there were so many
worthy people that we had to excise and
for whom I prepared prophet ory
introductions like daniel patrick
moynihan as a matter of fact i had
wondered why that wasn't an William
Sloane coffin the correspondence between
Bill Buckley and William Sloane coffin
was hilarious Clare Boothe Luce comic
again why Hubert Humphrey well now here
I must interject and say if enough of
you go out and buy jizz you increase the
chances of there being a sequel yes with
all the obituaries and eulogy that
begins did not have room to include a
torch flickering but not quite dead
please join me in thanking James for us
a precise examination
thank you all very much for coming I'm
Lindsay Craig president of national
review Institute as Jack said we're so
grateful to all of you for your support
so that we can Bing bring programming
like this thank you to James for writing
this book we really appreciate it
Christopher of course we love having you
come to our events and participate in
them obviously you're a dear friend
thank you and Ryan again another great
moderating job we appreciate thank you
all have a great weekend
[Applause]
[Music]